(upbeat music)
- What's a cute girl like you
doing sitting all by herself?
- I'm waiting for somebody, so.
- Oh, waiting for me?
- No, I'm actually
waiting for my boyfriend.
- Well, you know what they say?
A cute girl like yourself
shouldn't have to wait for anybody.
- You know what?
- What?
(farting)
A girls gotta eat.
I can leave you a business...
(farting)
- Hey
- Who was that?
- This guy literally sat down,
farted, and then just left.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Hey!
You, yeah, what are you thinking?
- Oh.
- Who does he think he is
anyway with that mustache?
- I know, I hate ironic facial hair.
(upbeat music)
- Hi.
- Oh, hey guys.
Sarah, over here.
We made a series.
- It's coming out November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here.
- There.
- Here.
- Over here.
- Click here.
- You got it.
- If you look in the
area, then you can see it.
It will be release 2015, November.
Okay.